We will talk about what will save the world,
and we can never save the world without politics.
So what's your take on the anger amongst people
against the political class?
Well, in Lincoln's day there was even anger
against the political class, and Lincoln himself,
in one of his early speeches as a young man,
attacked politicians, saying 'I know', to
his audience, 'that you'll understand that,
because I am a politician myself.'
So there's always been this strain, particularly
in American politics, of scepticism about
politicians.
We're in one of these periods where there
is such scepticism, but it runs deeper.
It's not as deep as the crisis that occurred
in the 1920s and 1930s, which turned into
a profound crisis of democracy.
We may be on the eve of such a thing, where
people feel that democracy itself is not only
inadequate, but also the obstacle to resolving
their problems, and that order is more important
to them.
I don't believe that that'll ever happen in
America, but we have such a figure in Donald
Trump, who exploits disorder in order to claim
to be the authoritarian figure to impose order.
This is a profound question, beyond the United
States, that affects the West.
It affects both conservative parties and social-democratic
parties.
In the United States, it particularly affects
the Republican Party.
The Democratic Party always had problems.
While it showed a split in its primary between
Bernie Sanders and Hillary Clinton, it is
now much more unified than the Republican
Party.
We will see what the outcome is, and we will
know it when we appear at the conference.
But there is still a problem - an intellectual
problem, a problem of ideas, a problem of
culture, particularly in the European social-democratic
tradition.
I believe this is not the problem in the United
States, for American liberalism.
We have many different traditions to draw
upon that are quite diverse.